Trascrizione: Gloria Tadiello
Revisore: Piero Cavallo
Buongiorno a tutti.
Oddio, sono un po’ emozionata.
Comunque, oggi io sono qua perché
vi voglio parlare delle mie origini.
Le mie origini sono state lente.
Io mi ricordo che a cinque anni
fissavo il foglio,
mi perdevo e poi tornavo normale.
Scrivevo, mi perdevo e poi tornavo normale
e questo mi capitava
più e più volte al giorno.
Spesso mi sentivo dire:
“Stai attenta, mi segui?”
Ed effettivamente avevano ragione.
Io per prima pensavo di essere distratta.
Solo che continuava.
La mia fortuna però
è stata trovare delle maestre
che avevano capito che c’era
qualcosa che non andava.
E a questo punto le mie origini
hanno preso una piega diversa.
Io soffrivo di epilessia con assenza.
Tutti, bene o male, conosciamo l’epilessia
nelle sue forme più classiche,
ovvero con le convulsioni
e con le scosse tonico-cloniche.
Però riconoscere l’epilessia
nelle sue forme meno eclatanti,
come l’epilessia con assenza,
o piccolo male,
è un pochino più difficile.
In questo caso,
le crisi sono caratterizzate
da sospensione della coscienza.
Colpisce il bambino in età molto piccola,
intorno ai cinque anni
e rimane come imbambolato,
con lo sguardo perso nel vuoto.
Se durante queste crisi
lui viene chiamato, non risponde
e se gli viene chiesto a cosa
stesse pensando, lui non se lo ricorda.
Lo sviluppo neurologico in un bambino
con epilessia con assenza
è assolutamente normale.
Sono solamente
questi brevi attimi di assenza
che possono far scattare
un campanello d’allarme
nei genitori e negli insegnanti.
Ora vi voglio far vedere una foto.
Questo, quello che vedete qua,
è un elettroencefalogramma.
Queste onde qua,
queste un pochino più grandi,
erano momenti
in cui il mio cervello si spegneva.
Pensate quanto può essere difficile
per un bambino con epilessia con assenza
seguire la lezione in età così piccola,
stare attento ad imparare.
Immaginatevi un bambino
che fa un dettato
e la maestra detta e lui scrive.
Ogni tanto, magari, salta una lettera,
poi una parola.
E magari alla fine
ci prende anche un brutto voto.
Spesso questo disturbo
non viene identificato
e quindi il bambino viene etichettato
come uno con la testa tra le nuvole,
un po’ svogliato e disattento.
Perché ho deciso di raccontarvi
questa storia?
Perché io sono stata fortunata.
È stato identificato il problema
e sono guarita.
Ma per molti bambini non è così.
Molti vivono la loro vita
al di sotto delle loro potenzialità,
precludendosi opportunità
di studio e di lavoro,
solo perché nessuno si è accorto
quale fosse il problema.
A volte mi chiedo che cosa sarebbe stato
di me se non mi fossi fatta curare.
Chi lo sa, magari non avrei...
Avrei fatto le superiori, sì, sicuramente.
Con un po’ di difficoltà.
Magari non avrei fatto l’università,
oppure non mi sarei laureata.
O magari non avrei fatto
l’anno all’estero, in Costa Rica.
Questa è una foto di me
e dei miei compagni di classe
l'ultimo giorno di scuola.
È stata un’esperienza bellissima.
Pensate a quanto mi sarei persa
perché convinta di non poterlo fare,
di non essere all’altezza
o che non facesse per me.
Ora vi faccio vedere
un’altra foto, questa qui.
Questa è la mia famiglia
e questi sono i miei genitori.
Per un genitore ammettere
che il proprio figlio nasca
un pochino più lento rispetto agli altri
è difficile.
E ovviamente colpendo il bambino
in età così piccola coinvolge
anche tutta la famiglia.
E nel mio caso aver avuto due genitori
attenti, molto pazienti e attivi
ha fatto sì che io risolvessi.
Prima vi dicevo
quanto può essere difficile
per un bambino con epilessia con assenza
stare attento in classe ed imparare.
Le elementari per me
non sono state un periodo semplice,
ero sempre un pochino indietro
nell’apprendimento,
ero sempre un pochino
più lenta rispetto agli altri.
Ma i miei genitori hanno fatto in modo
che io non mi sentissi mai in difetto.
Ecco, io nella mia vita
non mi sono mai sentito da meno.
Poi, se proprio devo dirla tutta,
non è che me la sia passata tanto male,
perché ogni volta
che mi portavano a fare un esame
o a fare un accertamento in ospedale,
dopo facevamo tappa al McDonald’s
o a fare colazione al bar.
Quindi, se proprio devo dire la verità,
io non mi sono accorta mai di nulla
e me la sono vissuta proprio bene.
Però, molti genitori
non sanno da dove partire.
Quindi io vi dico
che la diagnosi è molto semplice:
consiste in un elettroencefalogramma,
un esame assolutamente non invasivo.
E la cura è altrettanto semplice:
basta assumere dei farmaci per un periodo.
E nella maggior parte dei casi,
come è successo a me, si guarisce.
Ora però mi voglio rivolgere a te,
che come me,
sei nato con un’origine
un pochino più lenta rispetto agli altri.
La vita a volte ti mette davanti
a delle situazioni difficili,
ma bisogna reagire.
Bisogna circondarsi delle persone giuste,
farsi coraggio,
e a piccoli passi, piano piano,
da lento si può diventare veloce.
E in alcuni casi, anche un po’
più veloce rispetto agli altri.
Bisogna trasformare una debolezza
in un punto di forza.
Soprattutto, ricordati che non sei solo,
non lo sono stata io,
ma di certo non lo sarai neanche tu.
Grazie.
Grazie mille.